へっへっ
こんにちは Dr.はじめ だ
はい、というわけで冒頭にもあったとおり、今回256個のスポンジを準備しました。
私は、スポンジに無限の可能性を抱いている。
スポンジっていうのは何がすごいかっていうと、皆さんご存知のとおり、吸水力
そうなんですよ。
あ～
そうなんです。
スポンジ
まあ、基本的にはよく
食器洗い
洗剤とかで食器を洗うときによく使われるんですけども、
ものすごい水を吸収するんです。
一つだけでもね
即ち、スポンジを合体させて、巨大なスポンジを作ってみようかと思います。
多分２５６個も固まったスポンジは、私見たことないと思っているんで
まあとりあえず、まず前提としてスポンジには水を吸水する吸水力があると。
まとめて巨大な大きな一つの巨大なスポンジを作る
そのスポンジは果たして！
ちょっと実験したいと思います
これひょっとしたらね、もう世界を救うかもしれない
もしね、こう、大雨が続いて、
自分の家の床が水だらけ、床下浸水になると。
巨大なスポンジを置くだけで
全部の水を吸収して、助かるかもしれない
かもしれない。
わかんないですけど、今回はちょっとおふざけじゃないんで
スポンジの可能性を研究します
という訳で、一先ず、スポンジをまず一つにくっつけていきましょう
では行こう！
あの〜、一応、瞬間接着剤とか準備したんですけど
接着剤が付いちゃった面は、吸水しなくなっちゃうんで
最大限に力をぉぉ！！
最大限に力を利用してやっていこうと思います
では作っていくよぉ！
なるべく
そこがポイントです
わんわんティー
どうですかね
ちょっと余っちゃたのは付け足しておこ
はい！一先ず完成！あぁぁ…
一先ず完成しました！
あとはこれをいかにバランスを崩さずに
穴があると、そこから水がこぼれちゃうんで
しっかりとまず
OKじゃない？いいと思うよ。
いざ！す……あ！待って！
あ！何だす？待って待って待って！
どういう事？どういう事？
待って！痛タタタタタタ！
では早速接続に入る
接着剤と違って、表面が液体で塗れる訳ではないので
吸水する量をあんまり変わらないと見ました
ちょ、まず、グイッと行きますか
OK！横セット完了しました。
あとは縦です
縦はもうギッシギシに詰めていってもいいと思います
OK！ひっくり返して大丈夫だったら、クリアー！
あ、待って、絶対ダメだわ。
あ〜、もうダメだわ。てか。
とりあえずひっくり返そうか
こうなっちゃうんスよね〜
これはいいんじゃないんスか
あとは要点さえ止めれば
できた〜、できました！
低反発マットじゃん、もはや。
うおー！すごい！全然…
あ、待って、めちゃくちゃ…。
ごめんなさい。
強度はそんなに高くないです
はい！という訳でこちらの！
超巨大スポンジ
早速実験していきましょう
カモン！！
はい！という訳で、準備ができました
スポンジ君の頭の上に水を入れる
こういう口を作ったので
ここから水を入れていこうと思います
果たして、何リットルの水を吸収できるのでしょうか
で、ま〜、普通にやっても面白くないんで
僕の予想を言います
多分、３リットルぐらいが限界かなと思ってるんで
ちょっと３リットル、とりあえず入れてみましょう
で、３リットル入れる間、僕はこの
僕はこの、スポンジ君の下に僕のiphoneを置きます
もし３リットル吸収する事ができないようだったら
僕のiphoneに水が落ちて
Dr.はじめ、科学者としての、僕の仮定が正しいと思いつつ
今回の実験を進めとります
３リットル入ると思ってるんで
早速ちょっと水をあげていきましょう
頑張ろうな！！
まずは500mlから
これを２回入れれば１リットル分です
わ、怖ッ！
行きますよ、行きますよ、行きますよ
1本目
怖い、怖い、怖い
あ！大丈夫なの？
あ、意外と。
意外といけてる感じゃないですか、これ。
あ！あ！！あ〜〜〜〜〜！！！！
普通に出るやんけ！！
え！普通に出るんですけど！
はぁ？待てよ、待て待て待て待て待て。
めちゃ出るやんけ、ちょっと待って。
スポンジが悪かったのかな？
や、けど、吸水のスポンジでしょ、これ。
え、大丈夫なはずなんだけど
また、水、拭かなきゃ